good morning John okay this is I didn't
think this was gonna be as difficult as
it is it's a bit of a tradition here on
vlogbrothers who is this beauty what are
you let's find out what's inside the box
don't hurt yourself that's the impor
jeez I almost gotten let's calm down a
little bit what's inside that box
another bomb sorry this is heavy it says
beautifully foolish endeavor
I don't do it toward yourself that's the
one ruled inside this box let's just cut
the camera down here well do far inside
the box pieces of paper or into the
vlogbrothers tradition of signing tens
of thousands of sheets of paper here
they are just do one on camera here will
this be the one you get voila
how do you know it's this one it'll have
a very slightly hairy 8 that's this one
that's the worst thing I could have done
I was just watching your video from 2011
when you were signing The Fault in Our
Stars very quickly and you were a little
frazzled and to be honest with you I'm a
little frazzled but John more important
than that
it is I think somewhat unusual that
someone has to sign tens of thousands of
pieces of paper and so I'm taking this
opportunity to do something I'm gonna
test every single permanent marker I
could find to see which one is the best
one and then I will know that no one has
ever had a chance to know this before
I'm gonna be the one who figures it out
because I have that I had the
opportunity to be that person I bought
like $250 of permanent markers John I
want to know what the best ones are so
as an example here's the stack that one
black sharpie did and here's the stack
that one red sharpie did you can see
that these sacks are different sizes but
we have a lot more pens to go through so
yeah it's time for me to destroy to just
destroy these pieces of paper I'm sorry
I'm not destroying them I'm adding value
to them though I am destroying this one
I hated that why did I do that
a beautifully foolish endeavor is the
name of the book and it is out July 7th
2020 and yes signed copies are available
for
pre-order now if you've already
pre-ordered an unsigned copy you can
cancel that order it's not a big deal
pre-order the signed copy it will be
great please do that and when you do it
a tiny signal will be sent to a computer
somewhere and that computer will say
hold on this person has reserved a book
and then later up these pieces of paper
that I am signing right now will be sent
to a binder and they will be bound and
to finished copies of a beautifully
foolish endeavor and then those books
will go off to book distributors and the
places where the little mark was made
inside of a computer they will say this
one is that person's and this piece of
paper will go to you and I think that's
pretty amazing and then only and only
then will your debit card be charged it
actually doesn't get charged until they
send out the book so that's interest and
just to round out the video I got some
questions on Twitter
this one's from Gabriel lots on these
cursed Kirby's my thoughts are no both
birds and sheep have flocks are birds
sheep or our sheep birds chirp so I
doesn't Tarzan have a beard he doesn't
want a beard he shaves and finally Kyoko
asks how do you coat well new season of
RuPaul's Drag Race is coming out so
that's gonna help we're working through
it we're gonna do it as a species
collectively individually I'm gonna do
what John did you know that I have a y2k
Kalen this is actually before the year
2000 the next millennium time remaining
but you can set it to any time and I
have it set to the time when my book
comes out which is 130 days 2 hours 48
minutes and 55 seconds from now so it's
coming it's closer than it's ever been
in now it's even closer and now it's
closer still John I'll see you on
Tuesday I'm fine